James what was the main attraction to
you and lure for you to come and get
involved in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe I have three boys and and two
out of the three of them are just love
comics and superheroes and you know all
the rest of that and and and I have made
many many films and done television work
and all the rest of it and none of it
has been for kids or my kids
specifically some of the films I've made
probably for my eldest son would
probably be more interesting but I
wanted to make a film that specifically
my second son and then I also sort of
was watching my three year old at the
time who's now six when I first met with
Kevin Fahey and jeremy'll ahem I wanted
to make a film that they would really be
excise you were just talking about with
your with your heads in that you know
you do this sort of you know a careers
worth of work and the only thing they're
interested in is really the voice of
Jarvis well I wanted to do something
that my kids could really be excited to
buy him and and so this came along and
it was odd because apparently Joss had
gone him when he was in sort of the
initial casting conversations with Kevin
Fahey about this film he apparently came
in and said well I don't really have a
list for to play Ultraman I just like to
have James do it and Kevin said well
that's great because James's voice
effect that he'd like to do with home
was Marvel and and and we would like
that as well so it all sort of came
together nicely and then it is turned
out so absolutely beautifully in that
you know I just had such fun doing it
and such fun doing it and doing
something I had never done before and
couldn't even really conceive of
and was able to spend time with some
really wonderful people I really love
working with Joss Joss is a wonderful
wonderful guy and tremendous to spend an
evening having dinner with yeah Paul
yeah once again you've you've had a
chance to voice Jarvis for a while now
how fulfilling is it for you and what
exciting was it for you to actually now
transition from that into getting in
front of the camera as vision it's a
double-edged sword you know before I
would turn up and work for two hours and
they'd give me a bag of cash and then I
would just run away with said bag of
cash and now I have to turn up and spend
three hours in makeup and and work for a
living so that's a bummer but then the
work is really fun and you're working
with lovely people you know has changed
your certain and really creative people
who are playing at the top of their game
you know the nobody's making those
superhero movies like Marvel but maybe
in whatever iteration vision were to
show up again in any other Marvel movie
maybe he you know he has the capacity to
you know itself evolved and
self-generate maybe for the next time
he's just realized you know what I'm
gonna look like me we're in a track
trainers yes factly
you